Симуляція війни заради збереження миру.
На початку травня армія Фінляндії провела на заході країни військові навчання за участі трьох тисяч солдатів та 700 одиниць техніки.
Заплановані ці маневри були ще восени 2021 року. Причому разом з НАТО.
Вперше за всю історію Фінляндії більшість її населення - 76 відсотків - прагне вступу до Північноатлантичного альянсу.
Лише 12 відсотків проти, а 11 - не визначилися.
До початку повномасштабної війни Росії проти України за вступ до НАТО висловлювалися лише 20-30 відсотків фінів.
Шляху назад, до того статусу-кво, який був у нас до 24 лютого, більше немає.
Філософія фінів полягала в тому, щоб підтримувати добрі відносини з Росією.
Це було частиною нашої політики безпеки. Але події в Україні роблять це практично неможливим.
Довіра, яка існувала між Фінляндією та Росією, дуже постраждала.
Особливо гостро такий поворот у свідомості фінів відчутний у Лаппеенранті поблизу фінсько-російського кордону.
Адже раніше тут десятиліттями гостинно приймали потік туристів з Росії.
Я ніколи не сприймала Росію як загрозу.
Але тепер я постійно думаю про наш спільний кордон завдовжки понад 1000 кілометрів.
На цьому пункті перетину кордону доволі спокійно - почасти через коронавірусні обмеження,
але і як наслідок війни Росії проти України.
Вона за лічені тижні докорінно змінила позицію багатьох фінів щодо вступу в НАТО.
Спочатку я вважала, що нам не слід долучатися до військових союзів.
Але тепер я вважаю, щоб нам треба було зробити це давним-давно.
У мене ніби очі відкрилися, і тепер я розглядаю НАТО не як воєнну асоціацію, а як оборонний альянс.
Оборона шляхом стримування - основоположний принцип посилення НАТО свого східного флангу в останні місяці.
Суть у тому, що наявність потужного захисту запобігає нападу.
Саме на це робить ставку і керівництво Фінляндії.
Адже у Хельсінкі добре пам'ятають про радянське вторгнення наприкінці 1939 року.
Тоді, як і у випадку з Україною, Москва заявила, що її спровокували.
Понад три місяці фінська армія чинила запеклий опір, попри значну чисельну перевагу Червоної армії.
Агресія Росії в Україні роз'ятрила старі рани фінів і змусила їх діяти, пояснив президент Фінляндії.
Для нас вступ до НАТО - не рішення проти когось.
Коли йдеться про членство в Альянсі, ми прагнемо максимально посилити нашу безпеку.
Коли ви питаєте, а як Росія дивиться на можливість вступу Фінляндії до НАТО…
Якщо це станеться, моя відповідь буде такою: ви спричинили це самі. Погляньте у дзеркало.
Росія відкрито порушує міжнародне право та статут ООН.
Їхні звірства проти мирних жителів продовжуються.
Це не може бути прийнято від жодної нації, тим паче від постійного члена Радбезу ООН.
Якщо Фінляндія зробить цей історичний крок і подасть заявку на членство в НАТО,
це буде зроблено задля безпеки наших громадян.
Вступ до НАТО зміцнить все міжнародне співтовариство, яке відстоює наші спільні цінності.
У Росії намір Фінляндії приєднатися до Альянсу вважають "радикальною зміною зовнішньополітичного курсу країни".
У Москві наголосили, що дадуть відповідь на членство Фінляндії в НАТО кроками
"як військово-технічного, так і іншого характеру".
Членство в НАТО як фактор стримування російської агресії розглядають і в Швеції.
Як позаблокові країни Швеція та Фінляндія робили внесок у стабільність у нашому регіоні,
але все змінилося, коли Росія вторгалася в Україну…
Попри той факт, що наша політика військової позаблоковості добре служила нам понад 200 років,
я сумніваюся, що позаблоковість служитиме нам так само добре в майбутньому.
У НАТО наміри Фінляндії, так само як і сусідньої з нею Швеції, вітають,
не бачать жодних перепон для їхнього вступу і готові зробити це за пришвидшеною процедурою.
За різними оцінками, це може зайняти від кількох тижнів до близько одного року.
Нове членство, згідно зі Статтею 10 Північноатлантичного договору,
має бути ратифіковане усіма чинними членами Альянсу.
А Туреччина поки висловлюється скептично щодо вступу Фінляндії та Швеції.
Туреччина - важливий союзник.
Туреччина висловила певне занепокоєння, і, як ми це завжди робимо в НАТО,
коли є певні перестороги, певні питання, ми радимося.
Тож я впевнений, що ми зможемо знайти спільну позицію, згоду, консенсус, як діяти щодо членства.
Принаймні з точки зору стандартів НАТО Фінляндія та Швеція не матимуть проблем з відповідністю критеріям Альянсу.
Як партнери обидві країни вже десятиліттями співпрацюють з НАТО.
Гадаю, ми готові вступити до НАТО, якщо ухвалять таке рішення.
Ми тренуємося разом з партнерами з НАТО вже багато років. Тож це не буде проблемою.
Вступ до НАТО допоможе людям у містечку на кордоні з РФ почуватися безпечніше, вважає Лінда Бранд-Ахде.
Сподіваюся, ми долучимося до НАТО якомога швидше, що війна в Україні скоро закінчиться,
а Європа житиме в мирі й стабільності.
Тепер, переконана фінка, мирною та стабільною Фінляндія зможе бути лише у складі НАТО.